it just had to be always positive and
upbeat and whatever you need and
absolutely and
yeah that's and i it's so funny it's
like i didn't mind it was what i did and
it was completely fine until it wasn't
all of a sudden i just realized i
couldn't any more my dad talked to me it
was actually my dad my dad's a very
sweetest most loving guy and he's like
at what point are you gonna start saying
no and he goes you're always saying yes
to everything when are you gonna start
saying no
and i'm like oh gosh
so the next day you woke up and you said
you know what i'm going to change this
dynamic yeah and then i'm going to start
standing up for myself and the moment
you started standing up for yourself
cody didn't like that change in
personality no
he didn't hear you
i think that
he didn't hear her but he had no idea
what to do because i had changed so much
in the blink
everything changed and cody withdrew and
then i withdrew and we just withdrew
i know that your time in therapy is a
very private time
what did that on earth like what did
that peel back for you guys awful early
stuff that just never healed yes
stuff where i was like oh my gosh you
hold grudges way longer than i do way
longer
yeah i know stuff that shocked me
completely
we get to a point where it's great
experience and it's a struggle and it's
a great experience and it's a struggle
and
um and then we end up in las vegas after
she's told me she hates plural marriage
while she's at the same time
pretty much
you know telling the whole world how
awesome it is
she had mentioned to me grudges that you
could never let go of something i don't
carry grudges
no if somebody says i hold a garage
they're full of it they don't know who i
am
they don't know me
she also shared with me
that the moment that she started saying
no and not being the happy christine
that you liked that you fell in love
with
the woman that lifted your burden
that
that became a heavy lift for you
is it fair
to say that
or can you validate what she said we
could sit and um
say that um that he said she [ __ ] says
tell the cows come home and she's told
you things that i fundamentally disagree
with okay and all i'm doing now is
defending myself okay i'm going to ask
you now suki yeah i don't want to talk
about christina anymore
[Music]
you